but let's talk about this dude who got
shot man yeah KD 87 says cell phone
video shows suspect shoving several
women down before firing shots now this
I chose the story for the segment for a
reason because this is not the only
outlet that's trying to make it seem
like this guy was the bad guy first of
all if you want to be truly fair you got
a conflict going on two different
factions arguing over whether the statue
should come down or shouldn't come down
and they disagree now I think to be fair
you've got people trying to break the
law and other people saying don't break
the law so I always err on the side of
don't break the law so of course I
inherently have a bias towards the
people saying hey stop them from
breaking the law now if you wanna start
getting to the nitty-gritty of it all
really matters is when this fight breaks
out this dude in blue which they have
circled right here runs away they chase
after him yelling we're going to kill
you and start beating him with a
skateboard and then he draws his weapon
and it looks like he's hit in the face
or something and then he makes four
shots critically injuring a man so he's
in critical but stable condition I don't
know I mean I hope the guy's okay but
listen this isn't it this is a lesson
man and I mean this with no I mean it's
in all seriousness this is what happens
when people without guns start fights
with people who have guns you know you
know that should be a very important
lesson you know these guys are armed
don't run after them screaming you will
kill them because self-defense and
didn't look like he was armed they
didn't know he was armed but that's
that's not the important thing here I
doesn't matter if he was or wasn't right
correct but if this is this is exactly
what I've been talking about this is
what's gonna happen they're gonna show
up and guns are gonna go always they're
gonna start meeting up now they're gonna
meet up with people that have guns and
they're gonna start getting killed
cities you're not allowed to have gun in
New York you know how to have a gun it
all the guns that are in New York are
you then the cops or illegal well no I
think there's a Supreme Court ruling
right not that long ago and I think now
they're forced to somehow allow that
weapons I'm pretty sure in New York City
in every way I'm pretty sure yeah really
I haven't seen when we relive I lived in
New York for a long
trying to pull it up and I was under the
impression your there's no guns allowed
at all so iris was before it wasn't it
to get rid of illegal guns illegal guns
yeah yeah so I know New York is really
really strict yeah I remember you know
growing up in Chicago they had insane
gun laws okay and there was a Supreme
Court ruling saying you can't stop
people from bearing arms so Chicago
freaked out and tried passing a whole
bunch of crazy gun laws to make weird
loopholes to block people like you can
own a gun boy it's got to be like this
shape but it's gonna be like this size I
gotta be in your trunk and stuff like
that and then what happened was I guess
that got struck down too now you can
concealed carry in Chicago I'm pretty
sure and so all these businesses started
putting up signs saying no guns allowed
in their businesses so that they can you
know you they can't stop you from
walking around with one button most of
the business of Chicago are like you
can't come in my building because it's
private property yeah would you yeah so
it says I found an article that says in
much of the country cities can't enact
their own gun laws so it looks like
there's a preemption laws that limit
local regulations of firearms which must
know what you're talking about that's
from 2018 so it sound about right for
time frame yep I had already left New
York about up yeah yeah okay so I don't
know what book check this out check this
out
my main concern here as I agree with you
what the gun thing these people are
gonna get a cold splash of water in the
face to put it lightly yeah when they
start showing up in New Mexico and other
you know I'll put it this way this is
actually funny cuz I pulled up these I
got these two Wikipedia pages New Mexico
Albuquerque specifically is 40%
Democratic 34 Republican and 25%
unaffiliated not the most democratic
place Philadelphia actually is 82
percent presidential election democrat
that surprised me and even in
Philadelphia armed men are showing up to
defend statues so I'll tell you what man
people you know you only need 10 people
who are I doesn't matter what their
politics are 10 people to say yo you
can't come and destroy the statue for
these people to get a cold you know wake
up call when someone's like um that you
come at me I'll defend myself now but
this is funny check it out
the article here is trying to blame the
dude and here's what I find fascinating
gonna play this clip for you so in this
clip
Circle it they're desperately trying to
justify this guy's the bad guy but you
can clearly see in many of these videos
it's actually the women attacking this
dude it's actually the same woman over
and over again so look at their shoving
him around and then hit him with a
skateboard he straight-up swung it out
look at this dude you can see him so
watch the guy in blue now watch a
skateboard come for his face he's swung
a skateboard at him dude runs away you
can buy a woman hey you can really hurt
somebody with a skateboard oh dude oh
yeah seriously hurt somebody they can
kill somebody with scape absolutely yeah
the trucks are heavy that I mean yeah a
board by itself if you swing it on the
edge it's like that that can hurt but
then you add the the weight of the
trucks did and you hit him with the
trucks too that was a truck hit to the
face you go it right if you go a full
series of the truck it's the metal part
on the bottom if you go a full swing
with that like a baseball bat yeah get
shot kill shot yeah man that hit him
right in the nose oh yeah dude force it
in this guy's this guy's running away
right easy what do we got here this is a
facebook video and and and it's funny
like this articles look at this but
Steve Baca before he shot the protester
what a jerk
so look they saw him shoved that woman
right but wait for it she's grabbing him
and he pushes her off and it looks like
he says don't touch me and also notice
how that video cut in right then as a
player can likey her grabbing him yeah
how long was that going on that's now
now I've seen this too often where
suddenly another video will surface
where it's like three minutes longer and
you're like oh that's this yeah then you
see the whole thing
propaganda man man but to be fair take a
look at this next part it looks like he
does grab this woman right here he looks
like he instigated that attack on her
yeah definitely I agree so go check it
out she's climbing up and then he goes
up behind her and grabs her yep not cool
not a saint dude clearly not a saint
yeah well tensions are clearly rising he
grabs out all of this look at that he
pulls her down not cool bro so he should
definitely get charged for that in my
opinion that's for sure yeah but check
this out but they're all assaulting each
other it's like I'm not saying anyone's
right here they're all assaulting each
other yeah the one thing I did notice is
he walked away after someone already
swung a skateboard
yeah he went to leave you know and then
they're like let's get him let's know
they said we're gonna kill you you're
ready even more damning that's what so
that's what you say to someone what do
you thinks gonna happen that that right
there hearing that say someone say that
he should fear for his life then yep if
they said let's kill this dude yeah so
what and then I stopped eating it with a
skateboard he pulls a gun and shoots him
like I am not surprised yeah that's
exactly what I've what I've been worried
about happening yep
and it's this won't be the last time in
so he agrees so here's the other thing
that happens cuz I even I was calling
this guy militia guy because that's what
the news was reporting yeah because a
group called the New Mexico Civil Guard
showed up to defend the statue
eventually they stopped so I don't know
what their deal was entirely stop
defending it you mean yeah yeah yeah so
I think they were they were not so
heavily like there to just defend the
statute okay they were there because
there were no cops and these protesters
were marching around and they me riots
and they actually walked away and we're
going to sit back and watch them hear
the statue down this guy apparently has
nothing to do with them okay and so the
media reported this guy was part of the
militia he's apparently not the militia
guys were wearing camo this guy was
wearing a blue shirt yeah so they
actually published this message the New
Mexico Civil Guard they said there's a
lot of speculation and circling and
circling the shooting in Albuquerque I
want to let everyone know the shooter
was not a member of nm CGT our guys held
him at gunpoint until the police arrived
oh and mcg was not involved in the
shooting it was a moment of chaos and
our members took point to prevent any
more rounds from being fired and to stop
the angry mob from continuing to attack
and it our members had stepped away from
the protesters stepped back to watch
them Paul the statue down they were
nowhere near the shooter
they ran towards the shooter when they
heard the shots disarmed the shooter
preventing any more protesters from
being shot they circled two shooter to
the shooter to prevent any of the
protesters from their continuing attacks
our members did not pick aside they
stopped the violence on both sides and I
want to add to in the video you can see
the New Mexico Civil Guard actually
renders aid to the man who got shot I
saw so I believe them I do I don't think
got anything do with it yeah I think
this guy was like don't tear the statues
down and then they started this
everybody start hitting each other man
you know so
they're hitting him he's hitting back
you know he pulls a woman down someone
swings aboard his face they push him
around he runs away they chase after I'm
saying you know we're gonna kill you
they actually start beating on him pulls
out his gun
pop-pop-pop-pop that's it and these guys
stepped in and and put them got the guy
in the ground the guy immediately put
his hand behind his back hands mind his
back he wasn't running he's shot and
then just sat down and you know just
sitting there he was like yeah they were
running from him he was probably like
I'm glad that I didn't just die right so
this guy I got apparently got charged
with aggravated battery that's what I
saw so far okay they say you know it's
really crazy is that the city
immediately demonized the militia but
they were instigating or something like
that and it's like man how crazy is that
like these guys now putting us a more
like this is not one of our guys like we
tweet we stopped the violence and right
held this guy for the police to come and
get them
yeah how are they yeah well they've been
in that though that's like this is what
we're gonna have if there's no police
it's because these militia men listen
man they're actually doing a little
Ajith job now they're gonna demonize
them it's like I can tell you they want
I can tell you exactly why the mayor of
this town said the problem was the
militia because people like Mike Gundy
have no spine so for those that were
listening in the previous was it weren't
Mike Gundy this coach wore a t-shirt got
attacked for it and then apologized just
today these apologize so sorry for
hurting people's feelings for wearing a
t-shirt from öin when my ears it
actually I don't think I heard that him
say that he Apollo he yeah I think he
did like this I'm gonna have to go
rewatchable goes I don't a man while you
were watching it and from what I heard
it sounded like he was just kind of
saying I'm sorry for the things you're
going through kind of vibe I will talk
about that which I don't know if the
reasoner the reason I bring it up though
is just as another example of a
high-profile individual who immediately
gets on his knees groveling for
forgiveness from a mob that doesn't care
so when the mayor sees that there is
absolutely no support or spine from the
Conservatives who get targeted they say
i'm not gonna bow who's got my back on
this one you know if if a guy was a fan
of even OAM
won't tell you when i shut up more what
about this whole tucker carlson thing
hugger doesn't back down that's for sure
yeah but the and i seeso
people that are coming to his defense
that it's so that this proof that is out
there there there are they are standing
up for him there are a lot of people I
guess the issue is conservatives are
more likely to be I don't know keyboard
warriors I guess or the lack of it I
feel like a lot of them don't have
Twitter don't have they may have
Facebook with small circles but aren't
on the internet are there just love that
live in life to be right it's true and
they have kids and families and they
have jobs yeah did you just agree with
me yeah and also I think I think all
agree I will say that breath of fresh
air to be fair to the Conservatives too
there's a threat to your children so a
lot of people don't want to step up but
also it's an Tifa will use violence
against them if they come out yeah and
they will be demonized by the press if
they try to defend themselves just like
this story so there really is it his
vantage you know in my opinion you still
have to just speak up if people like
this Gundy guy or drew brees or whoever
else just told everyone to shut up yeah
then this would not be happening you you
if you you bend the knee you lose and
everyone loses around you but check this
out check this out because well I wanna
I want to jump into this idea we had
more guys show up in Philly now this I
find truly fascinating in reference to
what's going on like this New Mexico
stuff you know when when these guys from
unicorn riot came down they got smacked
around a little bit you know I'm not
happy about it I think that I think
that's complete BS these dudes then in
South Philly should not be whacking
putting on masks threatening a dude
who's filming telling him stop filming
and stuff and they're pushing his camera
and they're grabbing his bike so it's
like what anti-fur does and they strip
slashes the bike tires - yeah it is
you know that's gross man like why what
is what are you doing you want him to
leave but now you cut his transportation
I don't walk around this camera here is
do ya I really a threat to you alright I
don't get it but I'll tell you what man
they call these guys far-right okay they
literally are tweeting you know
far-right and right-wing you know
extremists or whatever it's like dude
you're you're in Philadelphia 82%
Democrat these guys are not Republicans
these are like Union Democrats you know
like they're like Union boys man
I'm assuming these guys work for some
you know some trade and manufacturing
yeah they were probably some offices two
machine shops like regular dudes yeah
they're wearing like football shirts and
stuff they think these guys are
Republicans or far-right that's insane
man yeah they're gonna get a rude
awakening when they realize you know
even even regular Democrats they're
gonna come out with baseball bats and
they're gonna they're gonna smack you up
a little bit right the Democrats are
fighting each other yeah yeah that's
that's that's for sure man
take a look I love this I pulled up the
the demographics for Philadelphia and I
find it hilarious it's eighty two point
three percent Democrat look at that
okay so let's be fair maybe these guys
who showed up fall into the you know
several hundred of the one hundred and
eight thousand Republicans it's possible
it's a chance yeah sure yeah I mean it's
a decently good chance sure I got to say
though I don't think these guys are
political I think for the most part
dudes showed up when they said some
crazy jerks want to come and smash up
our town yeah they came out with
baseball bats right dude I remember I
was at a protest on the south side of
Chicago Chicago of all places which is
like as blue as blue can be and a bunch
of these far leftists we're walking down
Halsted okay you know on the south side
in Bridgeport now if those that aren't
familiar with Bridgeport all right it's
South Side Irish it's by this US
Cellular Field okay used to be called
the Comiskey Park or whatever
it's where the Sox play this is a bunch
of low income low-income Irish people on
a south side of Chicago and a bunch of
like commie far-left anti-capitalist art
marching through screaming and you know
what happened right oh yeah they might
and they pulled their shirts off and
they started just home boxing people and
scenarios people I'm like so I lived I
lived I used to live over there for
briefly and I knew some of these guys
and like they're Irish not from Ireland
you know I mean like they're there
they're there you know great
grandparents or grandparents or Irish so
there are Americans there are Americans
but I mean like there they literally
called they call it the south side Irish
that's like they refer to themselves
that way okay it's this area where
they're all very proud of their heritage
and a bunch of and a bunch of commies
show up screaming in their neighborhood
and then the cops are coming out and
they come out and they're like what are
you doing like
what are you doing in our neighborhood
man who do you think you are these are
people who do not mess around these are
not Republicans you know these people if
they even vote probably vote Democrat
and a bunch of far leftist showed up is
there a box and I'm out you know yeah
and they and they beat the crap out of
some of these people yeah it's
interesting a lot of these issues or
things that we're seeing it's not even a
political thing anymore they live in
their neighborhood you know and they
could be Democrat or Republican and but
there there's they're probably friends
with with Jimmy over there who's
Democrat and Johnny over here is a
Republican well they're all gonna group
up and be like you're gonna come into
our neighborhood we're gonna we're gonna
box you I'll tell you what and that's
that's in a blue state right now we see
when it starts getting into the into the
country where it's a little more purple
you start and pull out guns then you go
a little further see what happens you
see what happens and these people riot
in in downtown Chicago or in Manhattan
and the cops are like oh we better back
off and what do we do and there's let'em
riot I got I got some advice for all all
these people man if you're listening and
you're one is an chief of people men
heed my warning you definitely do not
want to go into South Philly no you
definitely do not want to go to tune or
like South Halsted in Chicago and bring
that riot break bring that riot to
Bridgeport and they're gonna be people
rollin up with with big illegal guns
you'll be happy to see you dude I like
the people in the neighborhood I've seen
them pull their cars over for like minor
squabbles and pull out a chain and wrap
it around their arm and start swingin
and slamming it like dude these repeat
this is south side of Chicago man these
are people who are like you don't
disrespect me you know that I mean this
is and I gotta admit it's like I don't
like the violence but what I love about
America is that you can be a poor person
on the south side when these
neighborhoods and tell the rich dude go
after yourself
yeah you know these people come in you
bring that riot to the local pub know
what's gonna see whoever again dude
someone tweeted at me the other day
because I I've kind of been saying this
like you're gonna go you're gonna meet
some real Americans and you're not even
a happy someone tweeted me they're like
yeah I haven't haven't gotten any good
aiming practice since 73 and it's like
oh ho
this-this-this actually gives me hope
this South Philly stuff mm-hmm because
as much as I'm I'm worried that these
high-level institutions are being taken
over by lunatics and canceled culture is
getting like serious they're trying to
ban conservative news websites now I
imagine if it ever really got to the
point like when I think about some of
these neighborhoods like South Philly if
they actually came out and said we're
banning all hate speech
they didn't me Utley start screaming and
throwing bricks at him the riots would
be out of hand from people like these
South Philly guys they'd come out with
with guns and be like I don't care I
literally don't and they'd walk up to
these crazy SJW you know commies and
just be like nope so this is the
interesting thing these people aren't
activated you know that's a they go to
work they go home hang out their kids
and their family yep they vote they
don't watch the game but now the game's
politicized oh I'm telling you now
though they're waking up yeah because
they're football players they want to
watch the game and instead they're
talking about social justice so I can
imagine there's some like dude who's
like 40 years old and got a big you know
beer belly just got back from work sits
down cracks open a miller or something
or high life and he's like he flipped on
the TV and then he's like yeah let's you
guys want to watch the game he turns it
on and it's like now my question about
racial justice has to do with how many
police departments we really need and
they're like what is this change a
channel next channel
well when the players kneel what they're
really saying is what is this do give
can we watch some football or something
I can imagine what they must be thinking
when they show up to a Christopher
Columbus statue with baseball bats and
masks and guns aren't Republicans over
it yeah and I wonder I wonder you know
you know how you see riots when a
football team wins or loses yep that
that feeling these people have were
they're willing to riot for literally
nothing what do you think's gonna happen
you take that game away from them
they're not gonna be riding with you
dude they're not gonna be screaming on T
capital ista or smash the patriarchy
they're gonna be just screaming and
foaming at the mouth
waving baseball bats around yeah and
they're gonna come for you so this gives
me hope it does you know I recall my old
days living the south side of Chicago
and I'm like these people don't pay
attention and I imagine if they were
forced to pay attention all of these far
lefty crazy people would really regret
it
did I'll tell you what to especially the
Italians I think that's probably what we
see in South Philly because Christopher
Columbus was was put up there was a
lobbying campaign by italian-american
groups to have some kind of Italian you
know I can't I guess oh that's my
general understanding of it could be
wrong but something like that and now
you've got people coming in and
literally trying to target your family's
heritage or whatever oh yeah they're not
gonna stand for do this things are gonna
get spicy say the least thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you